[Music]
[Applause]
and tough guy
he's not soft like david pollock the
espn college football analyst he's not a
tough guy
david joins us now good morning david
happy new year how are you buddy
happy new year you're doing great
brother when's the last time last time
you were in a fight uh oh that's easy
when i was when i was a football player
uh i got a fight almost every single day
of practice
of every practice of my georgia career
it was a uh
it was a very consistent theme and it
was uh it was not
you look back on it now and you probably
would change the way you acted maybe a
little bit but i was
way too hyper competitive and i got in a
lot of fights and practice how about a
non-football
fight i've never been in a non-football
fight in my life
so i've never had anybody asked to do a
shot with me dan that's the problem i
guess i needed somebody to
do a shot with me but no i've never been
in a fist fight off uh
off of the football field in my life so
it's kind of it's kind of crazy
at least tom ronaldi could have done a
shot with you before he left to go to
fox
timmy and shouts would be a fun
experience probably you'd probably get
asked why a lot of what's going on in
your life all right um
urban meyer to jacksonville i know just
rumor speculation if you were him
what would you do well i mean if you
want to coach and you and you have that
itch to scratch
and they're going to pay me how much
like five six million dollars a year i
mean if i'm him then
um i could see it making a lot of sense
i just don't i think urban meyer is a
home run at any university
in any college he's already proven that
and but i just
nfl is a different ball game it's
different clientele you're dealing with
grown men and
you don't necessarily control them as
much as you control
college kids and control everything so
listen jacksonville's set up for success
dude it's
i mean all that money they have in free
agency they got the number one pick they
got two first round picks two second
round
i mean they're they're loaded it's it's
a great destination to be in
um you're gonna get trevor lawrence with
the number one pick one of the most
talented quarterbacks we've seen in a
long time so it would make sense for him
i wouldn't bet on him being a successful
nfl coach and turning that thing around
and
going and winning super bowls but i
would at the college ranks wherever he
goes i would say he's going to win
are you completely sold on trevor
lawrence being the number one overall
pick
let's say irvin goes to jacksonville and
you got justin fields there who you
coached
you watched that game so you sold on uh
trevor lawrence being no no doubt number
one overall i mean if you just watch
that game you go justin feels holy cow
he's the number one pick right like
that's the best guy on the planet
especially showing the toughness
checking the football down
if you go back and watch a couple of
games throughout the season with indiana
and northwestern
i was like who is this guy i mean justin
fields started the season
after the first two games then i was
like justin fields and trevor lawrence
are neck and neck
they are right next to each other and i
got looked at like i was crazy and then
the next three or four games happened
and i was crazy and then you see
yesterday or the other day with the
the sugar bowl and you're like holy cow
like this guy's unbelievable so
i think that um when you look at when
you look at fields he can throw the
football
accurately he's big he's strong he's
tough he doesn't see things as
fast as i would like to uh but trevor
lawrence is he he's very very special
because you
you just forget he's six six and he can
throw over top of everybody
and he's 230 he can break tackles and
he's you know four six speed and he can
run
so i think i think he's got all the
gifts now this i will say this i don't
think clemson maximized his gifts
like they didn't do it they don't i
don't know how well he throws over the
middle of the field dan like i would
love to be able to say
trevor can make all the throws but he
doesn't throw over linebackers between
safeties that offense is a premier
perimeter oriented offense it spits it
out it's a lot of screen so
if you look at bit height weight speed
um intangibles flowing locks great hair
like he's got
he checks a lot of boxes so i think i
think he'll be the number one pick and i
think he'll be very successful
i had an nfl scout who watched the notre
dame game and he said the following
notre dame still doesn't have
perimeter speed to cover and that's the
big issue here
um you know the offense
is they were trying to you know
establish the running game and keep the
offense off the field
they had a game plan but the scout said
you know you you've got to have
perimeter speed and it's
it's a glaring weakness with notre dame
so
is that all that is separating notre
dame from
you know clemson or alabama or ohio
state
100 that's it that that's all like when
they got destroyed in 2012
brian kelly changed the way he recruited
and changed the way he focused
and he got the line of scrimmage great
by the way their offensive line
notre dame okay i'll give you at the
lowest three in the country
third best in the country mauling people
great up front
physical um smart picks up blitz is
great at everything
but you watch devonta smith and he
throws a simple bubble route by the way
dan
if they were playing two-hand touch
football devante smith hillary scored
three touchdowns and had 135 yards like
they were not even close to fast enough
quick enough
on the perimeter that's the missing
components they need speed on defensive
corner in the skill spot they need wide
receivers that can go
i mean look at mckinley he's a great big
body six four
two thirty he can't run skarneke is a
great big body he's not separating from
anybody so
you you have the play calling ability
you have the line of scrimmage now taken
care of but now you need
some dudes some straight dudes that can
fly that's the that's the one lacking
component for notre dame are you sold on
devonta smith next level
oh yeah i mean he's he's as good as
you've seen man yeah but we've had
rugs before and i don't i don't know it
feels like there is that
alabama receiver and
he does have that burst like there's
something about him
he he gets around the corner and then he
just does something
that is completely different than
anybody else that i've seen in a long
time
he's he's like anthony carter at
michigan like he's thin
he's really small but you know they can
they can bully around in the nfl so i
don't know
i will say this about that i do think
you can get bullied in the nfl but now
you're starting to see so much so many
systems that protect you from that
and stacking wide receivers behind each
other i see my comparison for him is
marvin harrison
i think he's because his his routes are
exceptional
he catches he's not big but he catches
50 50 balls
really big he catches come he comes back
to the football
he's great after the catch and his
routes are very precise
i wouldn't have told you that about rugs
a year ago i'll tell you ruggs
can flat fly he can run as well as
anybody in the country but
he wasn't as detailed in his routes as a
guy like devonta smith davonte smith i
think
is a home run now listen jerry judy was
too but jerry duties
with drew luck and denver i mean your
situation definitely dictates how well
you can be but he's definitely a guy
he's a top 10 pick in the nfl and i
think he can do some damage in the right
system
but i also wondered about this though
david when you're trying to assess
like tua you know i i see tua with the
dolphins
and he feels a little exposed whereas
joe burrow i was curious
if he was going to be exposed not having
those weapons in cincinnati
uh you know justin herbert with with the
chargers
trying to assess how good a quarterback
is like i don't know how good mac jones
is
i i know that he's got a great running
back uh it got
got some open receivers there i don't i
think it's really hard for these scouts
to look at
some of these like dwayne haskins at
ohio state
he had one year and i could have hit
some of those wide receivers i think
in the game against michigan so i don't
know how you can assess
somebody for the next level based off of
the talent around them
and that's that's the hardest part like
the hardest part is understanding that
just like
justin herbert i think is the best
example you mentioned because justin
herbert played in a scheme
that sucked and and by the way you
looked at you
you look at justin herbert he is he is
just like trevor lawrence
including the hair like big tall strong
athletic
you watch him throw a football and
you're like yeah yeah
i'll take it and then you watch the
system and how it was built and how it
was created and you're like
no this is an awful system they don't
let him play free they don't let him
um be him and make those big time throws
make big time reads
he goes to the nfl and he kills that's
the hardest part there's
comparing systems and what you're
working with i mean you look at tua
he had four first-round picks you can
throw
waddle and smith in there now with judy
and rux
yeah we can complete a lot of those
passes dan and look really good
but i'll tell you the one thing that's
different to me about mac jones
mac jones pocket presence and accuracy
is pretty stupid like
he is not an athlete and he'll tell you
that by the way he'll tell you i'm not
very athletic
but he slides he goes through his
progressions and i love the way he
checks it down
to uh the one worry i had about two was
he played in an
all rpo based system it was all rpos and
he's really good at it
you don't live on that in the nfl joe
burrow played quarterback
like an nfl quarterback like so and then
herbert played in a system that was
was terrible and i didn't love watching
it so yeah it's
exceptionally difficult to do it uh if i
don't talk to you before the national
title game ohio state will win
because of what justin fields and that
offense being who they were
in the bowl game like what we already
saw they
they have the by the way when we were
going through clemson
ohio state clemson ohio state like i was
like ohio state better on the offensive
line ohio state veteran receiver like
ohio state
they have all these checks and all these
all this athleticism on the offensive
side of the football
justin field just wasn't using it if
justin fields plays like that
we're in for a heck of a showdown he
just has a tendency to play
different than that and more aggressive
and make more mistakes and not see
things as clearly but
um if he plays like that then we're
going to see the you know we've already
graduated by the way like
college football is college football is
now college football has gone to
it's basically madden except for we put
it on the exhibition mode
we don't put it on all madden anymore
defenses stink
like it's so hard to get stops because
there's so much speed there's so much
cheating
by the offense because you're allowed to
block down field and all this garbage
i'll get into
another time but um so offense i think
you're looking at if he plays
similar to that we're looking at a high
scoring 40-something to 40-something
entertaining game
great appearance as always david we
appreciate you joining us as always
happy new year and uh
and we'll hopefully talk to you soon
happy new year dan thank you
thank you bud it's david paula a former
cincinnati bengal
first round pick david will be on site
uh college game day
in miami it uh will be the national
title game alabama ohio state that's
next monday
january 11th